I've gotten better at that as I've
gotten older better at forgiving people
and not holding grudges and not being
upset at people and if I see someone
that I had a problem with in the past
just give him a hug you know I know I
don't care yeah I think it's it's it's
it's not healthy to carry around grudges
and you make you feel good sometimes
that feels real good and it feels real
bad to keep that hate and anger inside
of you it festers away and you think of
well if he says this time I say that
mm-hmm [ __ ] him and he shouldn't have
done this well I shouldn't have done
that but yeah but I only did that
because he did this and you play have
these little stupid arguments in your
head instead of just saying hi and just
being friendly or saying you're sorry or
saying hey man oh no I don't have a
problem there was a guy that a few years
ago I I drove my car on the street and
much college second in the evening I see
a tall guy coming at me and he asks for
you beg for money
put down my window this guy swears true
story he's that guy that used to bully
me in school I say I don't want to say
his name
I say hey wait a second I parked my name
I parked my car parked the car go talk
to us the hell you doing here man's eye
and and he thought that would be angry
because when he see me he saw it like
like now I'm world champion you know
like I can't beat the beat him up you
know back in the day was like three
years older than me was bigger it was
beating me up in the bus this guy now he
see me is I kind of a scare I get out of
my car you don't know you don't know if
he should run or nuts I go to him I say
hey what you do here man zach is like
you you say yeah I know but things
doesn't go well for me you know I'm like
all right it's like like man you're a
tall guy good-looking like what you're
doing here man's like I give him what I
have left on me you know like I don't
remember like I got a hundred something
I give him I say get out of here man's
like you're full of potential as I get
out here man like when I was young and
when I wanted to be like you you're a
tall guy a man you you you're
good-looking is like full of potential
so he size check is I was like no no
problem and then he say thank you George
you get out then I don't I don't hear
about him
few few weeks few months later I go to
my paradise for having dinner there my
dad say you know come to the house a few
days ago this guy I'm like yeah I met
him say yeah he said you met him in the
street but now he said he came to thank
you
he came he wanted to talk to you but I
said you don't live here and I didn't
want to give you a number he said he
said look he said hey Georgie talk to me
and he said so he changed my life now I
have a job and I and I feel good I just
want to say thank you to him and it
feels so good
now you just went when I met him and I
dunno get angry at him like you know
because it's it was still there we did
very bad stuff to me when I was young
but when I see him it made me feel good
kind of a relief now you know and this
guy when I was young was beating me up
in the bus all the time it was
ridiculous ridic lies me I'd like adidas
pants that you can tie it like this
it was like take enough so I was like an
underwear and found everybody in front
the girl he was beating me up all the
time and he was stronger than me was
like three four years older than me and
he was tall and strong guy is a key
player back in the day and yeah we
couldn't beat him even when Marshall he
was always stronger than me he hurt me a
lot like back in the day so my dad one
time I was got beat up in the bus I told
him because I came back with a black eye
one time in my life I told my dad what
happened I never said anything about my
dad I say he's a guy in a bus he beat me
up I said I tell him the name of the guy
so my dad what he did he found out where
I'm from countryside so everybody knows
who everybody lives he goes to the house
you know I'll talk to the daddy say
listen stop can you tell your son to
stop hitting my son in the bus because
he need to be focused on the school and
that dad when my dad came back he said
hey I want to talk to his dad he's gonna
stop so he said his dad was like
drinking and stuff and it was beating
the [ __ ] out of his son so the way this
guy learn to communicate to his dad was
beating up he was drunk and beating him
up that's the way a committee was
community communicating with me
it was beating me
because he learned that the same way
from his dad to communicate so I was
just happened to be at the right right
the wrong time at the right time in his
life at the perfect you know I was the
guy that was getting beat so he's a good
and bad he was not a bad person to my
version of life - from my perspective he
was a terrible person back then he was
terrible I wanted to kill him yet like
many make my a my school time miserable
man I was a milli ated all the time I
was getting beat up a lad I was very
proud person so I used to to go fight
him all the time because I was proud and
at one point I found him so many times
that this guy is completely insane I
stop buttering him because I was what's
never giving up even though I was
beating getting beat up all the time
went to my eye oh my it was a bad person
but true is eyes it was a different
story and to his father was a different
story today everybody it was a different
story
yeah just to say that when I met him
that way we talk about like it feels so
good just to meet him in the street and
make kind of a peace and give him money
like yeah you beat me up you didn't but
you know why even though you did that I
give you the money and I make me feel
like I'm kind of a revenge better than a
revenge you make me feel like yeah man
you see without me you wouldn't have
nothing maybe to sleep or eat tonight so
I give it to you I still give it to you
if you do that to me that make me feel
much better than if I would like read
them up yeah and don't you think that
maybe that guy in him doing that to you
was one of the reasons why you became a
champion because you you got in the
martial arts very heavily because of
being yeah because I was beating up and
school maybe it was maybe it was not the
only guy that was beating me up all his
friend but he was kind of the the guy
that was all the girl liked and he was
like the taller stronger guy so he was
kind of the Alpha guy at the time maybe
it was an influence I don't believe only
one thing influenced me but it's many
things many cars that make that happen
but maybe it's one of the cause yes yeah
that's crazy
I could be wrong I could be right but
that's what that's my philosophy in life
that's how I think so everybody says Oh
George your true martial artist you're a
good guy as I thank you right I don't
have the time to explain to them
everything I just told you but that's
how I think in my when they say you're a
good guy of Zion
thank you I'm a [ __ ] good guy Evan
and me and myself I am Diane but it
makes me happy when people say that you
are good guy you try to be a good I try
to be a man you are
yeah trying to be that's who you are I
try to try to be good model good role
model I think is important for me